make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are continuing on with the
war of realms which I love I love the
war realms I'm glad it's turning out the
way it is because it's just like all
right like this is kind of what it's all
been building towards right like
everything with Jason Erin's run of Thor
and that's why I say Jason Erin's run
it's gonna go down it's like one of the
greatest runs in Thor history like this
that's it's a maze of the way it's
turned out but again like Earth is
really kind of on its last legs right
like the invasion of Malek has seemingly
came out of nowhere and so what it means
is like there's no safe refuge here and
so because that like with all this
unfolding the way that it is with Odin
basically undertaking the odinsleep -
recharges energies with Thor missing on
Jotunheim and Earth's heroes kind of
scattered to the winds trying to protect
what they can where they can it turns
into we can't really just kind of rest
on our laurels and play defense we
basically have to start going on the
offensive and so the plan of Freya is
twofold the first is to destroy the
black Bifrost of Malekith and the second
is to find Thor and I remember the
Bifrost itself was destroyed by a man
god when he attacked Asgard and even
Asgard itself was mostly destroyed and
so because of the fact of the blight of
the the Bifrost was eliminated there's
no real way to send anybody in or
anybody out so the results of this is
that they have to basically go to the
Black Bifrost of Malekith and destroy
that because that's how Malekith is
sitting his forces across all the nine
realms and consolidating them all back
on to Midgard and so at the same time
Thor is basically missing here again
it's one of those cool little things
here because what is amazingly can I get
like this return of The Secret Avengers
more or less now the Secret Avengers was
a concept that was established during
the heroic age right in the way this
worked out you had Joker saunas whole
thing where it was like revamp it all
right like rework revamp at all all that
kind of good stuffs the offenders were
disassembled we got the new Avengers and
then about seven or eight years later
the Avengers came back again and so as a
result of that during that whole era you
had an event called Dark Reign and Dark
Reign was a story that actually came out
of Secret Invasion
when you had Norman Osborn who became
the new director of shield and so as a
result of that with Norman Osborn taking
over he did what bad guys do and he
basically dismantled shield he
established Hammer and then tried to
conquer everything so finally once Dark
Reign finishes and then the whole thing
comes to an end Captain America is put
in he's basically put in charge of the
whole like intelligence organization
more or less he disbands ham or any
reform shield but when he does that he
creates like these small little Avengers
teams here and there and one of them is
The Secret Avengers is basically a black
ops team but what we end up getting here
is this mission for him to go to
Jotunheim to get Thor and then bring him
back
again basically The Secret Avengers
carrying out the carrying out the task
they always had so it's cool to see the
Secret Avengers coming back at the same
time what we do is we switch out of
Asgard and we switch over to daredevil
basically becoming the new Heimdall now
this is not something that we really see
very often right in fact I don't think
we've ever really seen this before where
Heimdall has allowed somebody else
especially an earthling to lift his
sword and then recreate the Bifrost but
what this does is it allows the by for
us to be reformed and basically like the
heroes really kind of have a chance here
as opposed to having almost like a
guarantee loss so it is kind of cool and
it is really interesting but again
switching back to the Secret Avengers
this is one of the cool little moments
that you don't see all that often in
Marvel Comics when people think about
characters like Wolverine right I think
about like his healing tattoo they think
about like his enhanced senses and so on
and so forth and even when you kind of
expand beyond Wolverine and you look at
characters like storm who can control
the weather things like that they really
only look at that through the lens of
like how it affects earth but when it
comes to characters like this they're
universal right I mean storks you can
control the weather on any other planet
she's on so long as it has a climate
that can deal with inclement weather
that provides that kind of that kind of
scenario and so because of that when it
comes to Wolverine his ability to track
senses it's Universal no matter where he
is in the universe he can pick up a
scent of somebody if they're in the
general vicinity now it's not like
Wolverine can pick up a scent on earth
and then travel to the other side of the
universe and then track this scent back
to earth
it's not that it's not that strong it's
not that capable but in this instance he
knows the scent of Thor and so no matter
where Thor is Wolverine can pick it up
if he's on the same planet essentially
like if the winds blow and things like
that and he can pick up the scent and so
that's literally when they're in
Jotunheim and they're like okay so like
we know how to find Thor now there's two
ways to find Thor here the first is by
you know using wolf rein to track his
scent the second is by following this
giant river of a frost giant blood
that's literally flowing through the
entire planet because Thor is killing so
many of them which is kind of cool it's
kind of Awesome but again the other part
of this is you also get to a degree
something akin to the Dark Avengers in
the sense that you've got Punisher you
got blade you've got Captain Marvel
um-um and then you've got you know
she-hulk so you kind of get like the
Dark Avengers so literally like The
Secret Avengers and the Dark Avengers
sort of reform now it's not really the
Dark Avengers in the traditional sense
the Dark Avengers were just villains
masquerading as vendors during Dark
Reign but it's the Dark Avengers insofar
as you're dealing with darker elements
of the Avengers team so that's why I
really kind of call it the the darker
there's really in name only but you know
with ghostwriter all those guys there it
really still just kind of serves the
purpose but the fact remains like with
them breaking in to startle hime and
then trying to find their way directly
to where to where the the black Bifrost
is things pop off exactly the way you
would expect because you've basically
got blade and Punisher on one team
that's not gonna go well for anybody
what you end up having is literally
punished for being like let's just kill
them all and you've got blade like I
agree and before anybody else is like
maybe we should think about that they
take off through mass and they start
attacking everybody which is kind of
cool to see because that's the way they
work right that's why they were so cool
it's because blade will just run in with
a sword and just kill everybody he'll
kill all the vampires he sees and
Punisher will just run in and just shoot
up all the villains he sees and like no
quarters given none of that stuff it's
just like you all you all have to die
and it's kind of cool to see these
aren't really guys who were well known
for their attacked they just go in and
attack things so it's kind of
interesting to see now from here we
switch back over to earth and we
actually change over to Europe and we
basically pick up with the fall of Dane
Wittman what looks like Meghan and the
new Captain Britain and this is
interesting here because what you have
is Malekith wielding the ebony sword now
this is a huge deal for if you're if
you're not familiar with the stories of
like of Black Knight which it's probably
fine if you're not Black Knight is
pretty obscure when it comes to like the
comic book landscape but the ebony blade
was a sword that was fashioned by by
Merlin now eventually was given to a guy
named Percy and basically he started
wielding it to like attack everything
and just like kill people which gave it
a blood-stained curse right so like the
blade to the blade basically like ash
for blood and it'll it'll corrupt the
person who wields it but in Marvel Super
Heroes number 17 in 1968 there was a
storyline that was established where
Merlin had put a kind of spell on the
blade so that the person who wielded it
could be injured but never killed and so
what that means is that as long as
Malick hist wields the ebony blade he
cannot be killed for earth superheroes
he's almost beyond reproach now right
like almost completely untouchable
there's really nothing they can do for
him but seizing control of this you
basically end up having him like run in
and just start like attacking things
again which is kind of cool which is
which is is is it is interesting and his
service purpose and I don't know why I
said that um that it was Carol Danvers
on the Dark Avengers team that's on her
she's not in she's not she's not there
she's on this frontal home she's in
Europe that was uh that was Freya um no
she's in Europe with like with the
existing Captain Britain
venom and Deadpool and then and then
actually will really like Wolverine
Wolverine is weird okay let's talk about
this for a second Pope Farina was
basically a character created by William
Stryker as during the events of like the
first X I think it was X 4 story or
something like that by Greg Pak and it
was basically trying to create like an
ultimate being that could kill mutants
ultimately it was defeated and then you
know whole furry and kind of went out on
his own and did his own thing it's okay
it's just Wolverine Hulk kind of merged
together and like tearing things up and
then of course venom being there and now
remember as far as I'm aware this is not
Eddie Brock denim this is venom without
this is the Venom symbiote actually of
his own accord without Eddie Brock
remember we covered that in the venom
stories with Donnie Kate's that you
basically had like the Venom symbiote
and Eddie Brock which separated from
each other and now the Venom symbiote is
out there doing its own thing
absent Eddie and so again like that
really kind of seems to be what's going
on here that theme is being maintained
either that or just kind of got snapped
back together and I was somehow totally
unaware of it so with that being the
case it's really just kind of like
marshalling what forces they can't and
it's kind of cool because we get the
sort of overview of what's going on by
Jason Aaron right that's one of the
great things about Jason Aaron riding
Houston Aaron will be like okay so
here's where things stand and then a
bunch of stuff happens and now here's
where things stand and then a bunch of
stuff happens it's really good he's
really really good I kind of keeping you
aware of like what all's going on at any
point in time and essentially what's
taking place here as the world's gone to
pot that Atlantis is basically being
attacked
namor the sub-mariner fighting like
flaming space sharks which is kind of
cool um you have like like the the
angels like literally the warriors of
heaven of the the tenth realm of the the
angels which was cut off by Odin a long
time ago ah they've basically invaded
what conned us they're attacking the
door mulashi I mean you've got like
rocks on oil and everything the only
thing really protecting Manhattan right
now is a fantastic for something for you
to notice Reed Richards looks like John
Krasinski I just want to throw that out
there he looks exactly like John
Krasinski I really hope somebody noticed
that I really hope so Eddy saw that but
again like switching back over to where
the Dark Avengers are in fartole hunt
once they actually accessed the black 5
frost
subtly flare comes to the realization
that the main Bifrost has been destroyed
yet again I said what the main Bifrost
being destroyed it seems like there
doesn't really seem to be a way to bring
it back you would expect there would
with daredevil basically wielding the
power of Heimdall but again it doesn't
seem like that's the case because right
now they're in the midst of fighting
everybody so literally you have like
this giant horde of dark hell's that
came flooding into into what remained of
Avengers Avengers Mountain and then
basically you have like daredevil all
them fighting him with not
enough time no real opportunity to
recreate the Bifrost because it takes
time and so with that in mind like the
the argument is okay if that Bifrost is
done and that my Frost is dead and what
it basically means is if we destroy this
black Bifrost there's no way for us to
get out of Sparta line we're trapped
here by the time they do reform the
Bifrost or find some way to basically
save us we'll be killed by all the
forces of Malekith because we're
literally in his base of operations and
so we're in the worst possible place we
could be to get stuck as the result is
we hold we hold the Bifrost we hold the
black Bifrost we keep everybody at bay
as best we can we hold everybody back
for as long as we can and we and and we
literally do whatever we can do in order
to keep everything going and that's
basically it
there's no real option there so what we
do is we pick back up with The Secret
Avengers again finally locating Thor but
here's the problem the Thor at the
moment right now is in the midst of a
berserker rage now Thor usually enters
the midst of this rage when battled
those on for too long and is literally
exactly what you expected as its Thor
when he essentially loses his mind loses
all form of sanity and really any
understanding of who he is and almost
reverts to an animalistic state it's
very similar in almost completely
identical to Wolverines berserker range
and so because of that if they walk up
to Thor right now and they say hey Thor
we're here to rescue you Thor will kill
them what you have to do is give it time
to calm down it's almost likely what's
gonna happen is you're basically gonna
have Thor like kind of come down off his
berserker rage hopefully you're gonna
have Thor fighting all fighting like The
Secret Avengers that's gonna make one
hell of a clickbait video hopefully
you're gonna have that but basically
they're gonna kind of like they're gonna
have to bob and weave dodge attacks
until he starts to kind of wind down
right like it's like letting your
adrenaline begin to drop off then it'll
be regular Thor who again is missing his
arm which hopefully it'll get reattached
but again it's cool more of realms is
awesome like it's it's an amazing story
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
purse
[Music]